hey we're going girl sing a song it's
3:00 we're gonna have lunch super late
lunch yeah it's way too bright I look
good I think
alright we're going over there to me
that giant thing to eat and uh what else
do it dance do it answer no all right
look at this I would call it if I look
like a little puppy oh oh that was way
too good
so rather premiere in one hour and I'm
about to put on I'm gonna do something
for you for us just for your words all
right wait here don't go anywhere I said
don't go in it you can't go in your poop
is down the toilet I'm gonna show them
my tuxedo but thank you for thinking so
highly of me you're gonna show them your
poop really I look good I'm it real good
we're gonna premiere it's gonna be
awesome so excited for the movie we set
up to we set up to go ahead for this
premiere larly so can't wait for the
movie
I'm not filming myself I gotta get back
to editing it's taking me for a blur to
edit and it's someone knowing all right
well I will I will talk to you later I
hope you have a good millisecond to next
video so here's us at the red carpet of
Enders game it's the first time I've
done any stuff like this and it was it
was a pretty weird experience but I
really enjoy watching the movie so it
was totally worth it in the end
and I think you both should check it out
once you get the chance so we're in the
black carpet foreigners came finally the
Chinese cinema is awesome
we just walked like around all the the
foot with photographs photography it was
crazy
my I'm blind Lily I made some good poses
I think I'll be pretty hot I'm going
forward it looks like I'm wearing a oh
okay there you go
we're in the cinema thingy enjoying some
free popcorns and the movies about Sark
I'm gonna film it for you of course so
you can see it on YouTube I'll film like
five seconds for you bros it's probably
super illegal but you gotta live a
little bit so we're at the party I'm not
drinking anything
and it's raining you can't tell but it's
raining in LA that's the coolest thing
about this party I'm just kidding
so here we are in a mall
I don't know what Chinese it's pretty
cool I really like it
I haven't seen any celebrities yet but
and it makes me sad every day have you
seen any celebrities yet we're working
on it
so play I drank too much it was part it
was great I don't drink anything it's
super early
we're just jet-lagged and tired and
we're walking
Nicole Kidman I'm walking on Nicole
Kidman right now
there you go Stephen I don't know what
she just said
Whoopi I'm gonna whoop you with my foot
there you go what we uh don't have any
cash bro no but I saw what point it is
no that's all right thank you anyway
I have to well um I don't have cash all
right who do we got here Christina
Aguilera I'm sorry just how to do it
Ricky Martin you too
don't give shoutouts on my shelf is this
weird okay
it was a good night I really liked the
movie might say like the movie it was
cool it's very cool I'm all excited
going back tomorrow and hazel was nice
to come too but it's kind of cool like
I'm very glad you know thanks to you
bros I can go and do cool stuff like
this go to premieres